well I'm back and thank you for your
patience have been in Europe for a
little over ten days now thank you for
your patience in this dry spell among my
channel but I feel like traveling is
important it gives you a perspective on
the world your YouTube channel might
take a hit yeah one day YouTube will be
gone and when it is I have a feeling I
will have wished I had traveled more one
is I'm back now got a couple movies to
talk about so let's talk about
[Music]
crazy rich Asians crazy rich Asians is
taking America by storm right now so
people have asked me in the comment
sections like with that tone like why
haven't you reviewed this movie hmm and
the answer is simple the trailer was
[ __ ] the movie looked like [ __ ] it did
was a terrible trailer the movie from
the trailer looked like it was some
straight-to-dvd movie that happened to
get a theatrical release but number one
three weekends in a row something's
gotta be there so the plight of this
movies is behind this girl they're
dating the guy goes back home to
Singapore to visit his family and brings
a girl along turns out they're not just
rich like john paul Getty rich she's
like I did not know that about you what
world have I stepped into she's meeting
his family's little resistance there but
you know what all you need is love not
true they're just sorry John Lennon you
can't be right about everything which if
you strip away the fact that it deals
with his family being crazy rich I
essentially just described a meet the
parents remake for it but a lot of the
entertainment in this movie hinges on
the fact that he's really rich and she's
not because she's trying to deal with it
this lifestyle porn is what it is what I
mean by that is it's really cool to see
people who are so rich they don't have
to worry about the things you and I
worry about that's why we had shows out
there was like lifestyles of the rich
and famous and we would look at their
houses whoo I want it that's why I liked
Entourage I like the fact that this guy
was hanging out with his friends they
were just doing Hollywood in fact in one
scene of this movie is the girl is
hanging out with all the wives and the
girlfriends and the guys out there at
his bachelor party I was like it's like
Sex in the City Light and entourage
flight had a kid and I'm watching the
kid I would never talk someone out of
watching this movie if you're out there
for a date night crazy rich Asians great
date movies that's really what this
movie has going for it it's a sweet
movie I walked out of the movie like
that was a romantic comedy I don't know
actually is it a romantic comedy or is
it a romance any time a movie has to
Chandra's in his description like
romantic comedy action thriller I'm sure
it is both those things but it's more
one than the other so it's just more
romantic or is it more comedy it's more
romantic I mean there are some clever
quips and some of the side characters do
lend themselves to comedy they're the
ones that make it a romantic comedy as
opposed to just a romance so not all the
comedy landed for me there were a couple
of characters I'm like you're acting
like a cartoon but those are the
nitpicks of the movie like I said the
movie's a sweet movie with a sweet story
it's sweet story is a story you've seen
before really she's a middle class girl
meeting the boyfriend's parents who are
all loaded with money or super
traditional how do you think
work out how do you think it's gonna go
it goes basically there I said it did
tug at the heartstrings a bit that's all
I require of romantic comedies or
romances if you can just make me go oh
that's nice you've won you've won me
over the ones that don't the ones that
screw that up that's when I kill you on
my channel this movie keeps itself from
being too basic when it has a strong
message about maybe the old way should
evolve I like that romance among the
human race it's kind of a universal
binder everyone gets it you know that
because the human race hasn't died out
romances how in our brains we're like
yeah totally I did I think the human
race should go on so in that the movies
playing to human nature on the other
hand people love seeing people live the
lives that they dream up and in that
this movies playing to human nature
those movies coming at us from two
different angles max I thought crazy
rich Asians there's a good time no
alcohol required apparently I wait weeks
before doing videos on things now
between my Godzilla trailer video and
this don't worry I will get you the
reviews of the movies coming out this
weekend by this weekend uh promised are
the ones that choose to do anyway that's
that's my caveat all right so crazy rich
Asians have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]